just doesn't seem worth the effort so
the final trailer dropped for rise of
Skywalker and I'm not happy about the
fact that I felt nothing watching it
that actually really bums me the heck
out because every other Star Wars
trailer got at least some little
something out of me even solo like a
couple of moments in those early
trailers so I was like oh like one
little thing so to get the hair to stand
up a little bit
the force awakens trailer had it in
spades
rogue one pulled it off the the trailers
for last yet I did it solo did it
probably the least prior to this but
still had a little bit I died honestly I
felt nothing on this I don't think that
makes it a bad trailer I don't think
that even necessarily means it's gonna
be a bad movie it just means that I feel
very detached from this franchise right
now
yeah I think ultimately the reason that
this trailer did nothing for me is that
it's one of those trailers that banks
very heavily on its weight as a
concluding chapter and a story that I've
kind of checked out from I imagine
watching this trailer and feeling the
way I did is probably similar to
somebody watching a trailer for endgame
if that somebody didn't care about the
Marvel Cinematic Universe they'd be
looking at it going boy this thing
certainly seems to feel like it's
important but I don't care that's kind
of how I feel about this except I used
to which is just really irritating and I
can't even pin it on one thing I'm not
even really gonna blame it on the last
Jedi but I've just I've lost the passion
for Star Wars I just can't bring myself
to care and I don't know why like I've
had things that I've enjoyed go sour on
me but I and I've gotten angry about
that I don't ever remember feeling this
numb feeling this resigned and again
that's not me saying this movie will
suck I hope it doesn't I plan to see it
I would very much like to come away
having enjoyed it I don't like not
liking things and I really don't like
feeling little to nothing from something
that used to give me something make me
smile there are two instances that got a
glimmer of something out of me
and even that was minor one was this
nice little moment of Ray and Chewie in
the cockpit of the Falcon just sort of
pausing to look at each other very kind
of smiles that was nice
and the one shot of kylo Ren almost perk
me up because I still find him to be a
very fascinating character I'm I'm not
sure how good a character he actually is
I feel like that's one of the problems
with a lot of the new characters they're
difficult to judge until they're done I
feel like I don't really get Rea still
and I've never like been like Oh Mary
Sue like no I've never felt that about
her I've been fine with her but I also
feel like I don't know how to judge her
because I don't totally know what's
going on with her
I get thin a bit Poe I'd yet the kylo
Ren I feel like there's an arc going on
that the payoff Ford is gonna heavily
favor whether I end up deciding I like
or dislike him as a character right now
I'm leaning towards like because I think
he as a character has been really
interesting at least to me and my
sensibilities but I mean it doesn't mean
they'll pay it off well and of course
there's the thing that I brought up last
time I talked about a Star Wars trailer
which is the Emperor's back and that
honestly that more than anything is
probably what's killed my interest more
than my distaste for the last Jedi and
again if if you are relatively new to
the channel and you haven't seen my
thoughts on the less said I reviews
there I stand by all of it and my quick
sum up is I it's actually not dissimilar
to how I feel about series 11 of Doctor
Who I have a fair amount of issues with
it but they're not the ones that the
loudest and most of annoying critics of
the thing keep shouting about so you
know but I still don't so you can care
for it but I don't think that's why I
feel numb right now I don't even think
Solo made me feel that and Solo was a
solace solace
cash grab of a film that was a bad idea
from the get-go and had very few
highlights
but the Emperor coming back was always
top of my list for things I never ever
wanted to see happen and having it
happen not only kills my interest in
this movie but it makes me retro
actively annoyed that I ever cared about
the previous two if this was always in
the cards and this was always going to
happen I don't know how much time I want
to devote to explaining why I hate the
Emperor coming back so much but
simplifying it as much as I can
bringing back the Emperor and negates
Return of the Jedi as far as I'm
concerned it negates the victory they
didn't really win because he's not dead
and yeah I'm gonna consider that to be
the case even if he did in fact die but
somehow came back if he came back if
they didn't then that to me means they
didn't win my heroes didn't win and in
fact at this point they're dead and I
was prepared to roll with it with Han
being dead and Luke being dead and the
presumption that lay is gonna be dead
because we lost Carrie Fisher so I know
they're shooting around that as best
they can but I imagine there's gonna
have to take her out of the narrative I
was more willing to accept them being
gone if it was something that happened
later it's something else yes the first
order very clearly picked up some of the
resources some of the mentality of the
Empire but it was a new thing it was a
new thing
with a new
generation of fighters who were going to
be the ones to take it on fine
I still don't love it because I would
like for my years to have had their
happy ending they won they should be
able to have their happy ending and not
die in another war 20 whatever years
later 34 however freaking long it's been
but the idea that the Emperor either
because he was in fact never dead or he
had some contingency plan where he could
still come back even this much time
later if either of those this case and
one of them has to be one of these
things has to be the case then that
means that the heroes of the film's I
love didn't win ever they didn't win the
war that were fighting and then died in
another word that they worked honestly a
bit too old for which a little
depressing but I was prepared to roll
with it instead they die in an extension
of the war they thought they won but
never really did
the idea of the emperor coming back at
all was a very large reason of why I
never got into the Star Wars Expanded
Universe stuff you know well before
there were gonna be more movies when it
was you know dark Empire and throne and
whatever else cuz there were there were
clones and there was this and there was
that like I Return of the Jedi was a
victory I was supposed to be a victory
why can't they win I was prepared to
accept new threat I'm not prepared to
accept same threat oh wait you're heroes
who are now dead and can't finish the
fight didn't ever win this plot
development put such a bad taste in my
mouth that it does sour force awakens I
can't say it's ours vladus Jedi cuz I
already didn't like Clash at it but I
like to force awakens I really did I
enjoyed it
I there's now a bad taste in my mouth at
the very thought of watching it again
because the end implication of all of
this really looks like it cannot escape
the idea that the good guys never won
and I hate that I really really really
hate that I'm not gonna go so far as to
say this ruins the original trilogy
because no the original trilogy is
timeless and amazing and if I choose to
ignore these new films and focus on that
original trilogy at the exclusion of
these then they are untouched and they
are untainted it helps that it's
completely different creative teams so
it's not like I have it in the back of
my head oh god George Lucas was always
gonna do this and it was in his head
even when he did for eternity I know I
don't I've got none of that tainting it
so I'm don't make the leap that I'm
saying this ruins my childhood cuz it
doesn't what it does do is force me to
cut off my fandom at Return of the Jedi
because this is tainted force awakens
for me I still enjoy rogue one I'll
still give it that and again I'm not I'm
not even gonna be like this whole thing
has been so stupidest but I know but
it's for me and I only ever speak for me
I just can't care now
like I said I'm still gonna see it and
I'm not going trying to hate watch it
and I know some people will say you
clearly made up your mind before you
went in I mean maybe I don't think so I
haven't made up my mind it's going to be
bad
but I do have an existing opinion about
what appears to be the major plot
contrivance of it I can't not have an
opinion about that it's a thing I know
so I'm gonna have an opinion on it and
yes it's a negative opinion I want this
to prove me wrong I really really really
do but I don't have faith in this
anymore and that bums me the heck out I
love Star Wars you know that that
lightsaber they saw at the front end was
a birthday present and I loved it
and I've done Star Wars cosplay and I
still love that original trilogy
I even like Revenge of the Sith don't
really like the other two prequels but I
do like that one
Star Wars is always been a part of my
life I don't remember watching Star Wars
for the first time so I don't love not
looking forward to them this is not me
saying nobody go see it this is not me
saying this err of my childhood this is
not me saying you know even shaking my
fist saying how dare you I'm just saying
something that I used to love is now no
longer for me is what it feels like and
that's not a good feeling even if I
don't like this movie I hope other
people do there were certainly people
who like the last Jedi I'm glad they got
something out of it I didn't and even if
I don't like rise of Skywalker even if I
end up hating it I don't wish that on
anybody else cuz this doesn't feel good
so those are my thoughts and my very
long-winded ramble on the trailer I did
very little talking specifically about
the trailer for rise of Skywalker but I
just I didn't what is there for me to
talk about I didn't feel enough to break
it down whatever your thoughts are on
any of this and if I've just depressed
the ever-loving crap out of you I
apologize
drop your thoughts down in the comments
and let's talk about a bunch of stuff to
do down there as well you can support me
on patreon maybe that'll pep me up a
little
failing that if you don't feel like
doing that there's the like and the
subscribe both of which greatly
appreciated links to my other social
media down below link to my book that I
wrote peel blocks blah blah blah all
down in the description click on them
they'll take you places or don't you
don't have to because at the end of the
day you're the council I'm just running
the meetings and until next time may the
force be with you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]